good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
it I believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all the major problems of the
world I started to believe life series
to try to focus on other topics not just
related to entrepreneurship but useful
skills ideas and strategies to help you
live a better life so today we're going
to talk about how you can detect a lie
everybody lies and as always guys if
you're listening if you hear something
that really inspires you please put it
down in the comments below and quick
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired as well and when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick with
yourself as well
enjoy
[Music]
lying has evolutionary value to us as a
species researchers have long known that
the more intelligence of species that
large of a neocortex the more likely it
is to be deceptive
now you might remember Koko does anybody
here remember koko the gorilla who was
taught sign language koko was taught to
communicate via sign language here's
Koko with her kitten sir cute little
fluffy petkin koko once blamed her pet
kitten for ripping a sink out of the
wall we're we're hardwired to become
leaders of the pack it starts really
really early
how early well babies will fake a cry
cause wait to see who's coming and then
go right back to crying one-year-olds
learn concealment two-year-olds Bluff
five-year-olds lie outright they
manipulate via flattery nine-year-olds
masters of the cover-up by the time you
enter college you're going to lie their
mom and 1 out of every 5 interaction by
the time we enter this work world and
we're breadwinners we enter a world that
is just cluttered with spam safe digital
friends partisan media and genius
identity thieves world class Ponzi
schemers a deception epidemic in short
what one author calls a post truth
society it's been very confusing for a
long time now what do you do
so let's start with the first thing this
one that everyone wants to know which is
what is the body language that indicates
line now unfortunately there really
isn't one thing that is going to a
hundred percent of the time tell you
someone climb when you're looking to
detect line in terms of body language
what you're looking for are tells of
stress with regards to a particular
subject or topic and what that means is
that reading stress in the body is
actually much easier than reading
deception right stress comes through in
a lot of different ways and you can see
it in pacifying behaviors so that might
be rubbing of the arm if they're sitting
you can see people rub their leg you'll
see people start to touch right here
that's a pacifying behavior I'm going to
people chew on their lip cross their
arms curse their lips give you one of
those all of these things create lowered
like trying to calm yourself down
response and we do that in response to
stress now there's one thing that is
classic when people feel stress and it's
called blocking that means putting
anything between themselves and the
thing that is causing them stress so the
classic lying example of blocking would
be this blocking the mouth could be
covering the eyes or it could be an
object right right at the time that
you're supposed to you're asking them of
their line they gotta whip their phone
out or they simply move something in
between you and them on the desk
blocking is very common so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to show you two
patterns of deception and then we're
going to look at the hotspots and see if
we can find them ourselves we're going
to start with speech I want you to
listen to me I'm going to say this again
I did not have sexual relations for that
woman miss Lewinsky I never told anybody
to lie not a single time never these
allegations are false and I need to go
back to work for the American people
Thanks okay what were the tell-tale
signs well first we've heard what's
known as a non contracted denial studies
show that people who are over determined
in their denial will resort to formal
rather than informal language
we also heard distancing language that
woman we know that Liars will
unconsciously distance themselves from
their subject using language as their
tool now Bill Clinton is said well they
tell you the truth or Richard Nixon's
favorite in all candor he would have
been a dead giveaway for any live
spotter that knows the qualifying
language as it's called qualifying
language like that
further discredits the subject now she
have repeated the question in its
entirety or if he had peppered his
account with a little too much detail
and we're all really glad he didn't do
that he would have further discredited
himself Freud had it right Ford said
look there's much more to it than speech
no mortal can keep a secret if his lips
are silent he chatters with his
fingertips and we all do it no matter
how powerful you all we all chatter with
our fingertips I'm going to show you
Dominique strauss-kahn was Obama who's
chattering with his fingertips now
[Applause]
this brings us to our next pattern which
is body language with body language
here's what you got to do you really got
to just throw your assumptions out the
door let the science temper your
knowledge a little bit because we think
Liars fidget all the time well guess
what they're known to freeze their upper
bodies when they're lying we think Liars
won't look in the eyes well guess what
they look you in the eyes a little too
much just to compensate for that myth we
think warmth and smiles convey honesty
sincerity but a trained lies but err can
spot a fake smile a mile away can you
all spot the fake smile here you can
consciously contract the muscles in your
cheeks
but the real smiles in the eyes the
crow's feet of the eyes they cannot be
consciously contracted especially if you
overdid the Botox
don't overdo the Botox nobody will think
you're honest Clark freshman is a law
professor who runs a firm that trains
lawyers and negotiators on proper lie
detection techniques he says that while
there's no surefire method for detecting
Liars there are some advanced methods
they employ during questioning the
unanticipated question approach for
example is useful in cases where you
suspect someone may be trying to cover
something up this is based on the idea
that people in these situations will
often fabricate stories without
considering all the details so if
someone commits a crime but their alibis
says they were at a restaurant when it
happened ask them questions that they
wouldn't expect like where was the
restaurant bathroom located a person
who's telling the truth will have no
problem answering these details but a
liar may struggle did you ever steal
anything valued at more than ten point
five dollars now are you basically a
dishonest person basically a dishonest
person this polygraph examiner and
retired FBI agent doesn't need a machine
to pinpoint a liar the eyes are a window
to the soul you can see right through
them what do they expect from asking
questions most look at this guy's eyes
before Jason answers he looks up to the
right looking up and the right means
you're making up something here are
visually picturing something that's
never happened you know that's a lie up
to
you're remembering something only
problem it's the opposite for lefties
like Jason so he's telling the truth
shifty eyes could also indicate
dishonesty the moment they complete that
lad they look right back at me because
they're trying to see whether I'm buying
what they're selling Liars typically
explain events in simple terms since our
brains struggle to build a complex lie
judgment and evaluation are complex
things for our brains to compute as the
u.s. president once famously insisted I
did not have sexual relations with that
woman
and finally even though Liars keep
description simple they tend to use
longer and more convoluted sentence
structure inserting unnecessary words
and irrelevant but factual sounding
details in order to pad the lie another
president confronted with the standard
proclaimed I can say categorically that
this investigation indicates that no one
on the White House staff no one in this
administration presently employed was
involved in this very bizarre incident
let's apply linguistic analysis to some
famous examples take seven-time Tour de
France winner Lance Armstrong when
comparing a 2005 interview in which he
had denied taking performance-enhancing
drugs to a 2013 interview in which he
admitted it his use of personal pronouns
increased by nearly three quarters note
the contrast between the following two
quotes first okay you know a guy in a
French in a parisian laboratory opens up
your sample you know john frenzy
so-and-so and he tests it and then you
get a phone call from a newspaper that
says we found you to be positive six
times for EPO
second I lost myself in all of that I'm
sure there would be other people that
couldn't handle it but I certainly
couldn't handle it and I was used to
controlling everything in my life I
controlled every outcome in my life in
his denial Armstrong described a
hypothetical situation focused on
someone else removing himself from the
situation entirely in his admission he
owns his statements delving into his
personal emotions and motivations thank
you guys so much for watching
I'd love to know what did you think did
you enjoy this video did you learn
something new are you going to apply
this somehow to your life or your
business is there a liar that you want
to check out and see if they're telling
the truth or not leave it down in the
comments below I'm super curious to find
out I also want to give a quick shout
out to Joshua Rodriguez from the Josh
speaks
thank you so much Josh for picking up a
copy of my book your one word and making
that collab video with me on your
YouTube channel I really really really
appreciate the support and I hope you're
enjoying the book that's why I feel so
honored to be able to directly pass this
video along to Evan so that he can share
his ideas on what it means to live a
life of purpose so thank you guys again
for watching I hope you have an amazing
day continue to believe and whatever
your one word is much love I'll see you
soon